幼女表俺の永江ははじめ
凌平8
あ素人ですこれじゃあ肇社長ですラップ中にフリースたいというのがあります今回それ
でパターンテイスト
バトルすることになりました
ん
スロートだけどねいうわけで僕全くエンドスロートなんで全然さんのラップとかわかん
ないって本当に何も知識ダサい状況で多分戦っても負けると思うので今回もなく深い脱
原有名な方等束さんにラップを教えていただくことになりましたけどだ
いやーすごいつは本当にすごいことですよあと束さんに教えてもらえるんですよもう
やばいよと年6月受賞
youtube 界最強のラッパーらしいですどうしてくれるの
最強のラッパーですよいよう四葉葉香を陸地でちょっと
集めたけどそれを全部クビにしろちょっと同担さんからですね僕に向けていますの
フリースタイルのやり方をレクチャーしてくださる動画なので今回そちらを見ていこう
と思います
では行きましょうこんにちははじめまして re-style ダンジョンって
リーマン good モンスターをやっていると魂という名前でラップをしています
肇社長さんが上がっていくさと
ラップ対決をするということで以上一さんがユーチューバー界最強のラッパと名乗って
いらっしゃるそうなので大丈夫だと思うんですが
ティモシーバトルに話してポイントをあげていきたいと相座
mc バトルは即興で相手を罵る
一種のスポーツのような戦いですあくまで完全即興でやることが大事です
ドライブクロー
あと揚げ足ですねポイントとしてその3つが大きくあると思いますライムというのは
いいんです
東京例えば東京堂々
方フープ覆うでコインを踏んで打って言うそれをリズミカルにも憤怒フローっていうの
はそれをキュッだったり東京都
を急きょちょっと早く一帯に一番バトルにおいて重要なのがアンサーですね
揚げ足取りともいいますしやっぱり完全即興の言葉の結果なので相手が言ったことに
対してどれだけもうしようか返すかで判定はエアシーバトルはお客さんが決めるものな
ので地盤どう盛り上げるとかで重要なのでそこを大事に生きて頂けたらうれしいです
それでは
足が実の実践をしてみたいと思います
追い始めを前にはない価値目お前はなんだ社会経験もないのに社長名乗ってんじゃねー
ちゃんと正社員雇用されてからいいやべあいどん兄お前の動画大抵が大量型資源を無駄
にすんじゃねー
資源ごみ思えの存在自体が消えるのみお利口そうに見えて実はコミュ障ってサイバー
エージェントのスタッフさんが言ってたぞ
つまりお前の存在が疑わしいった
お前の才能裏山ないいい湯チューバーお前のことを監禁してやりたいぜ九州カーン
ああうん disってるつらいですこれがラップってもんですよアバンティーズの
揚げ足を取る感じで向こうの中ホが悪いところとか実勢でいる所を狙ってそれはない
こともいいを踏んで倒していくという作戦でございますはいって言うけどたまさんがを
せよう
僕は通じずに守り早速アバンテ5ぞラットだとしてくるぜ
いようよ
[音楽]
はぁ
ああああああ
ん
[音楽]
ああああああ
んんん
[音楽]
ん
それでは
dj
fender b
[音楽]
で初めて行くぜ
これが代教諭チューバーラッパーや
そうは言えねーなー
高身長りゃぁああっエイダてただ勝っていくんだようーっ歌えを見捨てろえーっは
そんなルールがあるとは知らなかった2行ちゃんとボコってるからなあ見峠あ
精神います
それでは dj
ウィンカー p
おい育てお前そんなになぁ持って態度が女に
俺知ってぜお前向かせずツイッターでなんか変がポエムみたいなこと書いてんだよな
それ吹いたーーー
まじおもろい何ぞの髪の毛金髪ダーマ言えるとヒロがあってねーぞ
まーすまっちまじ面白い顔だねぇ
始めシャチをお前はとんだ真面目やろう
栄養こんな迫 mc に勝ち目は no
ってやんって言うお前だって髪の毛は襟足ピンク裏カーか中につけた頃あるじゃねーか
悪化し度が違うんだってあるんだこの野郎
もっとまちまちでかかってこいやーわーどらっち
俺昔タブチャンネルにだったよな
お前が戸出知って
ゆとこなぜかお前のかーちゃんに怒られたんだよ
どういうことだクリエイティブな動画だったらにお前の母さんはを若齢ても壊すだサー
おいもう1回ですてくれよお前がっ
くるところ
裏クリエイティブ変なこと言ってんじゃねーよトライクを狙う
あってん
ああああああああ
パーカーんもやしレベル a
ええええええ
は j
me
dee ん
ブーバー今年の大みそかの夜8時からパティてフリーター
アンゾーン東西工作高瀬に行われます今回はなんと
東軍と西軍に分かれてそのバトルが行われるのでここでしか見られないバトルがある
みたいです
r 指定さんとタモさんも戦いますしねまずネーレウスショーツ0調べる
皆さんもぜひこの番組を見逃さないように主張をしていてみてください
そして
あれば tv はですね登録不要で無料で皆様を見ることができますぜひ皆さん気軽に
見えるのでよかったら利用してみてください
強いフリースタイルダンジョンよってみたら思いの外なんかぽくなりました
そんなことないですかそんなことないです
私事ですが越冬オーケストラ本
今月21日だしました土田ば別ですもう名前もそのままです
僕の無駄に長いキャリアは13年分が詰まってますあと1月にワンマンライブを開催し
ます渋谷の www という場所で解散しますのでもしご興味ある方いたらよろしくお
願いします